Bonjour.
Aujourd'hui on va parler des vikings.
C'est parti.
-Euh, c'est ça ton intro?
-Tu crois que quand des vikings faisaient
un raid quelque part ils commençaient par
«bonjour, aujourd'hui on va voler vos biens,
partie 1 on vous pète la gueule...»
NON.
On est des guerriers oui ou merde? Générique!
Dans cet épisode nous allons présenter les
principaux traits de la société viking en
insistant sur quelques idées reçues qu'il
convient d'éradiquer.
Quand on parle de viking, on désigne en fait
un type particulier de Scandinave: il s'agit
d'un pillard ou guerrier, d'origine scandinave,
entre le VIIIe et le XIe siècle soit à la
période où ils font le plus parler d'eux.
On retrouve d'abord ce terme dans le vieil
islandais, puis en vieil anglais au XIXe siècle.
On ne peut donc pas désigner comme viking
l'ensemble de la population Scandinave, et
on leur a aussi donné des noms différents
comme les Francs qui les ont appelés Normands,
ou les Slaves qui les ont appelés Varègues.
Pour les scandinaves de l'époque, un viking,
c'est quelqu'un qui part en expédition.
Ils m'ont dit que je n'étais qu'un Scandinave.
Alors je suis devenue...
Un viking!
D'où viennent les vikings exactement? Nous
répondrons à cette question palpitante grâce
à une très jolie carte trouvée sur un moteur
de recherche quelconque.
Tout commence au VIIIe siècle en Norvège,
Suède et Danemark, où se trouvent les populations
scandinaves qui nous intéressent (en rouge
foncé sur la carte).
Pour des raisons que nous détaillerons plus
tard, ces scandinaves décident d'aller conquérir
des terres un peu partout: en rouge, orange
et jaune, vous pouvez observer les différents
territoires où les scandinaves se sont établis
du IXe au XIe siècle: on retient surtout
une partie de l'Angleterre, l'Islande, le
Groenland, et un grand territoire en Russie
où s'installent les varègues.
Les territoires en vert ne sont pas des territoires
où des vikings s'installent mais où ils
effectuent des raids durant toute cette période
de pillage intense.
Au delà de ces conquêtes et pillages, la
société scandinave était organisée sous
la forme de clans dirigés par un jarl.
-Par ordre du jarl, pas un pas de plus!
Aaaah !
-Les jarls sont élus, notamment pour leurs
capacités de chefs de guerre.
Ils sont à la tête d'un clan, à égalité
avec les autres clans alentours, mais n'ont
pas autant de pouvoirs qu'aurait un roi européen,
la société scandinave étant beaucoup plus
libertaire.
Ils sont également soumis aux lois qui existaient
déjà avant eux.
En dessous de ces dirigeants se trouvaient
les boendr, c'est à dire tous les hommes
libres et disposant du droit de vote.
En gros, ce sont les citoyens.
Il existe des différences entre eux, mais
ils forment le gros de la population Scandinave.
Dans cette société, les femmes ont un rang
inférieur à celui de leur mari au niveau
politique et juridique, mais ont de nombreuses
responsabilités dans la maison et lorsque
les hommes partent en mer ce qui leur confère
une certaine autorité.
Enfin, la caste des thralls était composée
des esclaves, capturés lors des raids et
qui n'étaient pas libres, ne pouvaient pas
voter, mais étaient plutôt respectés et
pouvaient même s'affranchir très facilement,
on est loin de ce que le mot «esclave»
évoque habituellement.
-La société était donc divisée en trois
ordres? C'est vachement original...
-C'était plus compliqué que ça, il y avait
les Godi qu'on peut associer vaguement aux
prêtres, les esclaves affranchis qui étaient
encore à part...
Mais pour faire simple on a les jarls, les
boendr, et les esclaves.
-Ok, ok.
Ces deux premières catégories se réunissaient
lors du Thing, une assemblée saisonnière
se tenant généralement au printemps, en
juin et en automne, durant laquelle les hommes
libres du clan débattaient, décidaient des
lois et rendaient la justice.
-Qu'on lui coupe la...
-La peine de mort n'était pas appliquée.
Enfin, très rarement.
-… Qu'on le bannisse...
Nous allons maintenant nous intéresser aux
invasions à proprement parler.
La première cause est assez évidente.
Outre la soif de richesses et de gloire, d'autres
causes sont invoquées comme le fait que les
premiers vikings auraient pu être des révoltés
ou bannis qui partaient voir ailleurs, ou
alors qu'une rivalité entre plusieurs clans
ait poussé les moins fortunés à aller essayer
de s'enrichir.
-C'est qui le lion maintenant?!
D'autres avancent encore l'idée que ces raids
et invasions soient une réaction aux tentatives
de conversion des chrétiens.
Et enfin, dernier argument:
-C'est trop facile! Ils sont tellement mauvais,
ça serait un crime de se priver.
-C'est ainsi que les vikings commencent par
piller des monastères, puis à s'imposer
de plus en plus.
On leur file des tribus, puis des terres pour
les calmer.
Dans cette partie nous reviendrons sur quelques
clichés tenaces par rapport aux combats vikings.
Les bateaux, d'abord, jouent grandement dans
la supériorité technique des vikings.
Sachez qu'à aucun moment on ne parle de drakkar,
le terme n'apparaissant qu'au XIXe siècle.
Les vikings parlent d'escheiz pour qualifier
leurs bateaux de guerre, et de manière plus
générale les bateaux sont des knorr.
-Knorr, j'adore.
-Ce sont des bateaux qui peuvent transporter
jusqu'à 70 personnes, et qui peuvent naviguer
un peu partout grâce à leur tirant d'eau
très faible: aucune rivière ne leur résiste.
L'exemplaire le mieux conservé est le bateau
d'Oseberg, que vous voyez ici.
Pour se battre, les vikings étaient vêtus
simplement afin de s'assurer une grande liberté
de mouvement.
Quelques cottes de maille ont été retrouvées
mais elles semblent rares et étaient probablement
réservées à l'élite.
Pour se protéger, ils avaient leur bouclier.
Passons aux armes, maintenant.
-J'suis prête!
-Ils pouvaient être équipés de haches mais
elles étaient plutôt des armes de jet, leur
principale arme était l'épée longue.
-Eh ouais.
-Et bien sûr, nous ne pouvons pas oublier...
Vous le sentez, ce silence? Ce sont tous
les participants au banquet du Valhalla qui
viennent de stopper leur festin pour nous
juger.
Moi, et mon casque à cornes.
Avec dédain.
La légende remonte à des casques retrouvés
au Danemark et qui ont été attribués à
Thor aux vikings.
-Ils ont été attribués à Thor, ou aux
vikings?
-Il s'agissait en réalité de casques celtes,
probablement cérémoniels, et qui dataient
donc d'avant l'époque viking.
Parmi tous les casques vikings trouvés, on
n'en a retrouvé aucun comportant des cornes
et les seules représentations historiques
de vikings avec des cornes, qu'on a retrouvées
sur des gravures, sont donc probablement des
représentations imagées.
Les vikings portaient des casques en cuir
bouilli ou en métal sans tous ces ornements
qui n'auraient pas été pratiques du tout
pour se battre.
J'te sens tendu, Harold?
Au XIXe siècle, la mythologie nordique inspire
les artistes dans de nombreux domaines:
musique, peinture...
Et c'est à partir de cette époque qu'on
trouve des représentations de vikings avec
des casques à cornes, qui sont ensuite reprises
dans Astérix, au cinéma...
Et qui restent tenaces même de nos jours.
Fort heureusement des productions récentes
telles que la série Vikings laissent tomber
ce cliché.
Merci Ragnar Lodbrok.
-Et ce casque là, il est histo ou pas?
-Repose le casque de Loki tout de suite!
Sacrilège.
Je passerai rapidement sur cette partie parce
qu'elle mériterait une vidéo à elle toute
seule.
Ou cent, ou mille.
Les scandinaves étaient polythéistes, ils
vénéraient un groupe de Dieux principalement
composé des Vanes, des dieux de la fertilité,
et des Ases, dieux guerriers et puissants.
Ces croyances reposaient sur une mythologie
complexe, comme l'existence de l'arbre-monde
Yggdrasil et de différents royaumes, la Terre
étant le royaume de Midgard.
Le fait que les vikings soient païens a pu
jouer dans la vision de barbares sanguinaires
qu'en avaient les peuples chrétiens.
Malheureusement, les principaux textes qui
nous racontent la mythologie scandinave et
que nous conservons ont été écrits par
des chrétiens! C'est notamment le cas de
l'Edda de Snorri, écrite au XIIIe siècle
et qui est l'une des principales sources sur
la mythologie nordique.
Il est très probable que l'auteur ait réinventé
la mythologie en y ajoutant son influence
chrétienne, ce qui rend la religion nordique
ancienne plus difficile à saisir.
A la fin du Xe siècle, les scandinaves se
convertissent au christianisme et c'est l'une
des causes qui marque la fin de la période
viking.
J'espère que cet épisode vous a plu et je
vous remercie d'avoir été nombreux à regarder
mes vidéos et à vous abonner depuis septembre.
Pour cette fois j'ai traité un sujet qui
m'avait été suggéré mais qui me plaît
aussi énormément, et si vous voulez en savoir
plus l'un des principaux auteurs sur les vikings
est Régis Boyer, je me suis aidée de son
livre «Les Vikings» pour faire cette
vidéo.
Alors encore merci, et à la prochaine!